You wanna know what women really value most?
Something that you as a man can do
and any woman will value you for this.
Protect us, keep us safe!
So simple, if you simply
number one: lock the doors at your house
if your wife/girlfriend/partner
whoever it may be is in the house and you're heading out the door,
make sure you lock the door.
It means that she knows that you wanna keep her safe.
Women are innately always on high alert,
and they worry about their safety probably more than men do.
Men probably don't even consider this.
If your woman is at home alone,
lock the doors
or at night lock the doors.
Double check.
Make sure those doors are locked in order to keep your wife safe
Womea/partner
whatever it may be.
This world is so crazy that you never know what's going to happen,
so why not take the extra measure just to lock the door?
That is what any woman wants, that's security.
You make her feel safe and protected.
You shouldn't complain or you shouldn't say,
“oh I forgot I'm sorry”
Set it as a habit so she always feels safe.
If she doesn't feel safe,
then got bigger or worries.
Your job is to protect us and keep us safe.
it's so simple.
So next time you're heading out the door,
make sure you lock it.
and females it's not too much to ask to have them lock the doors.
So don't feel bad for having them worry about your safety.
This should be a no brainer.
All men should do this without complaining or griping about it.